more than 60% of care homes have
remained covert free during this
pandemic and beach eknoll in Sheffield
is one of them Holly and Amara their
residents are so vulnerable here that
this is as close as families can get to
a precious moment the NHS has regularly
wanted to send to this home patients
whose Kovich status is unclear but
there's one person standing in the way
my role at regional is to get keep this
perimeter yeah it's yours too absolutely
yes and have you felt the pressure from
hospitals for example to to get into
this home yes absolute pressure you know
they want to discharge people but they
don't want to test and I'm not prepared
to I don't without a test and emic in a
bit busy situation Island is that too
much to ask
no no absolutely not because if we're
not asking that we're creating more
problems
no news Perhaps why you've hadn't zero
case that's look like nothing gets
through at all
from March the 19th the government urged
hospitals to discharge patients as soon
as clinically possible promising care
homes that they would be given clear and
accurate information about a patient 80
year old Barbara stead was admitted to
hospital on April of 5th after
fracturing her ankle during a fall she
was first taken here to Pinder field
hospital in Wakefield West Yorkshire but
then moved to nearby Jewsbury the
hospital wanted to discharge Barbara but
the care home refused to accept her and
that's because her medical notes appear
to have been altered in a way that made
the care manager suspicious this is
Barbara's patient discharge document
we've blanked out her private
information but down at the bottom on
the right is a section about whether she
was Kovach positive or not someone has
circled yes she is only then to scribble
that out and change it to no writing neg
or negative and on the next line down
you can see the words not tested but
temp meaning temperature of 38.8 that is
one of the symptoms of coronavirus well
pearl thanks for meeting me again
I know I wanted to talk to you about
this this document pearl Jackson has the
care home owners asked to authorize the
patient transfer the impression I
gleaned from that document was that
something didn't quite stack up so I
advise my manager not to take this lady
as I felt something wasn't right and we
weren't being it wasn't clear whether
she was covered positive or negative we
couldn't run that risk for the safety of
all the other residents Barbara's family
had no idea her medical records had been
changed in this way so I visited her son
John and his wife Leslie to show them
the form John how are you doing and
Leslie hello hello what do you think
about the form that I've just shown you
somebody's had a go at it so I don't
know when I see it's quite
straightforward there it's been ringed
yes
the written negative at the side and
ringed no what would you like to find
out about this whether he's right or did
she have it or didn't she have it
there's something wrong we need to know
what's happened now just over a week
later mrs. stead was back in hospital
again this time she developed a cough
and a high temperature and later tested
positive for Cobra 19 she since
recovered from the virus in a statement
the Mid Yorkshire NHS hospitals Trust
said the document was altered because
mrs. stead had not been tested when she
was originally discharged adding we
fully accept the way the form was
amended did not comply with national
best practice on documentation as the
amendment was not signed or dated and
could have caused confusion at what was
a very challenging time for everyone in
the NHS we intend to reiterate to our
staff the importance of accurate and
clear communication with care homes and
families and we are very sorry if this
has caused any distress clarity is
important and the government has said it
is testing all people discharged into
care homes but care managers we've
spoken to say tests are sometimes out of
date by the time they are asked to take
a patient it's absolute because I feel
as if I'm just fighting for residents
all the time just just to keep them
alive and I shouldn't be doing that
I shouldn't be doing it it feels wrong
hospitals have long relied on care homes
to free up beds on busy wards but this
crucial relationship between NHS and
care is now under pressure it comes down
to trust and it's being tested like
never before Nick Martin Sky News